If you're above 18, you watch the bird peanut, you are a terrible
person. You are a terrible person. You are a terrible person.
You are a terrible person. How does the eye of Sauron not turn
on this? It's just like, dude, immoral behavior is just always
massively incentivized. I don't know what to do about that. How
do you do that? How do you do that? How do you How do you get
rid of it? How do you fix it?
Okay, where do we go? I do want to go to the Devon Nash stuff.
There's a massive over investment
in Clippers right now because with enough Clippers, with enough
like top of funnel impressions, you can bot and fake the the
like botted views you have way more effectively, like way more
believably, and get sponsorships and stuff, okay? So, basically,
these people just pay a bunch of people to clip their stuff,
post it. I I've noticed this with Clavicular stuff specifically.
Lots of this stuff from Clavicular is not even coherent. The
stuff that they say in the title that's happening in the clip
isn't happening in the clip. Lots of it is totally incoherent,
okay? It's causing like the total slopification of most platforms,
which is pretty annoying.
It's just an effective way to astroturf
And the astroturfing actually leads to better results anyway.
That like once you get enough people who watch you, who view
you the first time, like if you pay to astroturf in this way,
as long as you have enough people watching the first time, you
could just get more and more and more people watching, and it's
like a snowball. So, it's like actually effectively good to bot
to most platforms. Now, the interesting thing from Devon here
to me, like how would an agency look at evaluating this and figuring
out how much they could trust in terms of people's metrics? That's
actually something that is interesting to me. So, I want to watch
this. I think it'll be good. Have you got the feeling recently
when you've been scrolling social media that you're being astroturfed?
That like you aren't choosing the influencers and podcasters
and like the brands and the the topics that show up for you.
You just are kind of a participant. Like the media doesn't feel
as real as it used to be. Everything just feels like it's just
being served to you, and you a lot of times you come across something
that you didn't even choose or know about to select. Like if
you feel like things are not quite real anymore, this video is
for you because if you understand this chart that we're going
to go over today and all of the things I'm going to talk to you
about, you're going to understand that content creation is a
gamed system now. This is not clickbait. This is actually true.
I'm going to go through step-by-step what is happening and how
a person and a group of people can propel any influencer to high
viewership regardless of content quality. You can be the most
uninteresting person ever, and you can still get boosted in algorithms.
And it it happens by tricking algorithms into featuring them.
It's a guaranteed way to gain followers, and it's basically pay-to-win.
So, in this video, we're going to explain step-by-step how it
works. We're going to go through some content that's in this
system, and I will show you literally that you can promote anybody.
You can promote anybody to the top in the world. It doesn't matter
what their content is. What most people think about the creator
economy and how it exists these days is no longer true. Algorithms
are being abused at a very high level. So, let's break it down.
Let's go through step-by-step how this works, and this image
here is absolutely going to be our Bible for this discussion.
When we look at this, you're seeing a month-long period. So,
I want you to note like this is 1 month. This is As of the time
of this recording, this is March to April, so just a few days
ago. You can see our number one guy here, Clavicular, who you
may have heard of. You may have been like, this guy just exploded.
I see videos of him everywhere. What's going on? I never searched
for this dude. What's happening? Has generated over 2.2
billion with a B, billion views in a single month. He has 69,000
videos that are on TikTok, Instagram,
YouTube, and X. 69,000 [clears throat] videos that are all about
him. How is this possible? Well, he has 1,610
paid Clippers that are working full-time to put this stuff out
on the internet. And likewise, you can see all of these other
influencers who with varying degrees have the same thing going
on. Here's Aiden. I wonder how they classify paid Clipper in
this case cuz Aiden sort of pioneered this to some extent. Aiden
was blowing up his own Clippers like to a large extent, okay?
And then I don't know, how do you even get these numbers on the
other people? I have no idea.
um he has uh 11,000 videos that came out this month, uh accumulated
about 714 million views. Now, this is the official
uh Clipping and Kick partnership. This is this is them just releasing
this information. This is not guessed upon data. This is like
I see. Oh, this is crazy. I see.
X Kick. Dude, what? Really?
Wait, are these guys paying their own dudes? Literally, the platform
that's doing it, showing you how this works. And we're going
to break down exactly what is happening here and how these guys
are tweaking the algorithm for this to work because it's both
fascinating and a little bit terrifying. All right? So, the very
first thing to understand about this, once you understand like
that this is happening and that there's like just a ton of paid
Clippers that are being paid quite literally to to post these
clips everywhere. The best part about the way they pay Clippers
is that it's like a scam. It's like inherently a scam.
Right? The way they tell you they're doing this is they go like,
oh, I'm going to pay you like I'm going to pay you 20 bucks,
50 bucks per like 100,000 views or million views or something,
But then I think for a lot of them, when they don't hit that
mark on an individual post, if you can't get to that mark on
a post, you just end up, yeah, not making money.
So, they do all this stuff, and there's just tons and tons of
of Clippers doing it. And then they just don't hit the mark ever.
They just miss with a bunch of the clips. You don't pay them
for a ton of work, right? Just various types of content.
The first thing we have to understand is that you start with
a central Discord server. Now, there are other ways to do these
campaigns, and there are plat Wow, this sounds Is Devon exposing
the Hassan infrastructure?
Is Devon exposing this thing that literally every influencer
is doing right now, but has been like tried to paint tried Certain
people have tried to paint this as something evil and like crazy
and and totally unthinkable?
What? platforms like Vera, which I or or >> What do you
mean that literally every influencer does this? What do you mean?
Hold on. Uh or does the one of those has some association with
Mr. Beast. And they operate the same way, but as platforms. But
for this video, I think the most interesting stuff that we're
going to go over is actually just going to be the platforms.
So, you can see here, this is uh the largest clipping server,
and you can see that that they once you get into the clipping
server, which I think has over like 20 or 30,000 people in it,
you can say, "Hey, you're just a few steps away from getting
paid for post content. Here's how you get started." You can just
go browse the campaigns, and you can go see that you can apply
for Kick streaming uh clipping program, which we're going to
talk about a little bit later uh as it relates to this. So, you
can just get paid by joining one of these servers. Um like no
problem. I was going to say, I've seen some clipping accounts.
It's gotten really disingenuous where I think people just like
lie about clips now. Like a lot of clips are just lies straight
up on Twitter. Like the clips are they nothing happens. Nothing
happens is close to what they say in the clip, in the content
of the clip, right? So, in the title or in the post. It's all
lies. It's crazy.
like no problem. And here is exactly how these campaigns work
step-by-step.
Um each campaign is going to be one
or a podcaster or a brand. Uh typically, like for the purposes
of this video, we're going to be talking about live streamers,
but this is this is being done for I I I I sat in these Discord
servers, uh the the invite-only ones and as as well as like the
public ones for the past like 3 weeks before making this video,
and it shocked a pretty much every major podcaster or like brand
that you've heard of has had a campaign in these Discord servers
in the time that I was sitting in them. And I And we're going
to go over it like specific clips and specific moments that they
want featured as well are also uh are also featured. So, like
it's a totally gamed system. Like there's just everything Everybody's
just creating doing paid clips that's popular
Uh how this system works is as follows. We're going to go through
it. Uh typically, when we think about platforms, these are all
going to be short form mostly. So, this is going to be clips
of this person's like long form. So, when I say long form, I
mean like a podcaster makes a video that's like 2 hours. And
then these paid Clippers will go through. They'll select 50-to-30-second
videos 30-to-60-second video parts or like 2-minute parts that
they think are interesting, and then they will post those clips
on these three platforms. There's a little bit of this done on
X. It kind of depends. Every campaign is a little bit different,
but most of them I've seen focus on these three platforms.
The way that you get paid is you have what's called a flat CPM.
So, a CPM is just the the amount that you make for 1,000 views.
And these will usually be between about 10 cents to 40 cents,
but I've seen ones that are as high as about two to three dollars.
So,
every campaign has a like payout. And you can see By the way,
this is all like massively incentivizing.
It's basically creating like decentralized networks of botting,
like view botting of different kinds, right? So, as this becomes
popular, it will become more lucrative to have your own view
bots so you can up your own CPMs. Like you could be the Clipper
with your own view bot network to view bot up your own stuff,
right? Your own network of accounts and all of this It's like
incentivizing the decentralization of all botting so that the
influencers themselves don't do it. The influencers just pay
Clippers to do it, and the Clippers are going to do it to figure
it out themselves. Now, maybe the prices are a little low, but
I'm guessing they're not that low. This feels like a more It
is just what Sneako and Tate did, yeah. Um It's very
I'll I'll pull up one. Uh just so you can kind of see like how
it looks. So, this is a campaign for Caleb Hammer and you may
have seen a lot of his clips and this is a separate Discord server
that's been created. You can see the payout for Caleb is 75 cents
per 1,000 views, that there's a minimum view required for payout,
and that there's a payment method, and it shows you the platforms
that it wants you to post on. So, you can post on TikTok, you
post on Instagram, you can post on Twitter, you can post on X
in this case. So, there there's there's an example of like a
a pretty prominent podcaster Um now, either it's his agency paying
for this or it's him, I don't know, right? But but he's um this
is the system that he's running. So, this is an example of like
a single campaign that's being run right now. Like this this
is a this is something that I pulled just a couple of days ago.
Um okay. So, they're offering a flat CPM of 75 cents per 1,000
views. Dude, 100 100,000 views minimum is pretty crazy. And in
this case it's 70 it's going to be 75 cents. I've seen like again
like $2, most of these are like 10 to like 50 cents or so. Um
you'll notice on that screenshot that I linked to you that there
was a minimum view payout threshold. So, what does that mean?
That means that um you you you can't have this this campaign
you don't get paid if you don't have 100,000 views. Now, um that's
not per clip though. So so what if we just like put the payment
deal details over here for a second. Um
the 100,000 views means the aggregate of you as an individual.
So, if you have two or three clips that get let's say you have
three clips that get 30,000 views each, you do not get paid.
But if you have three clips that get 30,000 views and then one
clip that gets 10,000, you get paid on the whole 100,000. So
so there's just that that's what they mean by minimum payout.
So, most of these people are creating for these campaigns they're
creating like 50 to 100 different clips across multiple different
accounts in order to reach this payment threshold and then they
get paid based on the um on on the CPM that was stated. There
are also bounties and bonuses. So, uh these show up in a lot
of individual clipping campaigns and you can see here uh we have
a bounty for pirate software. Uh again, I don't know who sponsored
this. Um I'm I'm just showing you
Uh it's crazy. I I haven't seen this work where they like provide
the clip they want put out. I didn't see that. Oh, but I have
seen Wait, I have seen him talk about like Kick monetization
and stuff. That's very >> What what's here? So, here's
pirate software. Um it says here that he it it's this is a payment
of $3,000 per million views, which is a multiplier, $300 for
100,000 views, and $3,000
for 1 million views. This is an invite-only Discord server. So,
this is not associated with the uh other Discord server that
I've shown. This is a a secret Discord server uh because I I
think they're a little bit more careful when they're trying to
promote individual clips and influencers um just from getting
people to know about how this works. But you can't hide from
Devin Nash. No, sir. So, this is uh pirate software gives a >> Oh,
nice. I love that Devin's actually doing a little bit of extra
stuff here. Dude, that's crazy $3,000
for a million views.
Now, next, the campaigns usually have a maximum cap. So, we were
not seeing that in the in the previous ones that I'm showing
you, but often times the campaigns cap it like 10,000 to 20,000
dollars, at which point they shut off. And and to be clear, I
don't think that the servers that are doing this are scamming
about this. Like you might think, oh like they cap it at $10,000
and every they don't tell anybody that that everybody else that
creates clips like there's a bunch of free clips that are done.
In my experience like like looking at this stuff and doing all
this research and studying it, there there isn't really a situation
like that. Like there's a pretty clear progress bar to indicate
when the cap has been reached and when you don't make money from
clipping anymore in in most of these cases. I haven't really
seen a lot of like black hat marketing in that direction just
to give credit where credit's due. Like my my interest is in
honest information. That's I'm not trying to make a value judgment
here. There'll be plenty of that later in the
Just for you to decide. So, I I didn't see that here. The most
of this stuff is is is very well put together. I mean by like
pretty elite operators and um it seems to be pretty above board
in I mean the the clippers get paid and they get paid a base
CPM, which you saw from Caleb's campaign that I listed here.
And then they also get to keep the RPM, which means like the
money the platform itself pays you. So, you get both the CPM,
which is like the the the the 75 cents per 1,000 that gets paid
out through the campaign, and then you also get to earn whatever
the YouTube short or the reel actually makes off of the ad revenue
just off of the platform. So, this ends up being a pretty good
deal for like second and third world people, which are kind of
the majority of people that are uh participating in this system.
The the you you get you you can end up probably getting like
an RPM of like maybe like $1.50 to $2 an hour. And for like a
first world or Americans or people like that, you know, that's
going to probably translate to about like like three or $400
a month. Like obviously the work that you put in, um you get
more. But for for people in in um
less advantage compa- countries that are getting paid by um that
are getting paid uh that can be very notable. [clears throat]
It's worth noting also that although I did Sorry, this this just
makes so many things make sense. Posted in my research >> All of
these payment that I too. So, they're paid via cryptocurrency.
Uh you're paid out via cryptocurrency. I guess in this case this
is a PayPal payment, so it might just be a direct payment. But
almost all the campaigns I saw are paid out via USDT. So, that's
a that's a cryptocurrency that's tethered to the dollar. So,
that's notable because I I think that's very favorable to third
like third world and second world countries.
Okay. So, um let's take a person like Clavik Yilder that we were
talking about before and you've got the 2.2 billion views on
top of 70,000 clips. Like how expensive is this campaign to run?
Like how how crazy are we talking here? Uh well, it's going to
be about 31,700
views on average for because we're just taking the 2.2 billion
and we're dividing it by um the 70,000.
Wait. Wait a second. Wait a second.
Doesn't that mean the average person doesn't even get paid at
all? And you get paid if you aggregate 100,000 views, you don't
get paid if your total clips are below that. So, there will be
some percentage of people that just don't get paid. But I I think
the majority do. Um but let's say that like in a situation just
to give you an idea where even like in a a crazy number where
like 70% of the views are free, which I I I think it's probably
closer to like 20% or 30%.
The math on it is it would cost 666,371
a month
even at $1 CPM just to run
Clav's campaign alone, not even considering all of these other
people.
literally hundreds
of thousands if not millions of dollars are being spent every
month
to do this. So, who's doing it? Who's paying for this? Right?
That's that's that to me is one of the most interesting parts
because The funny thing is the Kick clippers, I do believe that's
like Eddie largely, right? I think Kick took the like footed
the bill for a lot of people to get clipped by Kick specifically.
Num- number one, um this is there are not many people that can
set up campaigns like this. We're talking like management of
hundreds of people and like like this is elite operator marketer
stuff. This is not like the the streamers, okay? Very few of
these streamers are running these campaigns themselves. There
are people that are doing it. Like there are people streamers
that are running these campaigns themselves like to lesser degrees.
And and I mean you could also just have three people on your
Discord do clips for you and you could run a campaign like this
yourself. But when when I'm talking about these big Discord operations,
these are being funded and it's really interesting to see who
is actually funding them and what is actually going on here.
Because with respect to the streamers, I don't think that most
streamers are really business oriented. Um that's just been my
ex- The thing is is like to me, the way I looked at this stuff,
I knew that I could take money and throw it into this and I knew
it would be worth it. But the issue is when you get caught
fabricating views like this, I feel like that's supposed to be
a huge hit to your
And I think actually people just decided I think everybody who
bought it on Kick just got away with it and it's fine and you
get to bought and there's nothing anyone can do about it.
And there was just no upside to trying to remain
honest and not do that at all. There's like no upside to it.
And I understand some people got removed from KCIP or whatever.
But I feel like most of the big streamers didn't who were obviously
and it's it's just kind of sad cuz I I assume there'd be like
some downside, but there just hasn't been ever. There's just
never been a downside at all. Yeah, exactly, braid. It's funny.
If you're doing something bad and it benefits you, you just create
the impression that everyone does it and then you could just
keep doing the bad thing and nobody
I still feel like there's something to be said for having like
actual organic
like followers, viewers, all of this
But yeah, I don't know. It's it seems like all of this is just
To repeat to the rack streamers on Twitch watching full seasons
of TV, maybe. Maybe. >> experience being a top talent manager
for many years, I I don't think that um and now I'm an agent
on the brand side. I've always I've worked with thousands of
influencers.
Uh great great entertainers mostly, not the sharpest tools in
the shed when it comes to business with a few exceptions. So,
they're not going to run campaigns like this. Who is running
these campaigns? Well, let Uh Kick does not inflate that much
anymore, Rodimus.
I I don't think they inflate that much.
They inflate like a little bit.
I I don't even know that they inflate very much at all anymore.
One of the fastest come-ups in streaming, absolutely. Why do
you think you're the fastest growing creator in the world right
now? I think I have a lot of strategies
that
uh are are good for viral clipping engagement. I think Kick has
helped push me Like at some point, I I swear this is like the
time where I most feel like I need to switch outfits and just
go like Like there's a there's a broad meta problem with like
society right now in general, where just like immoral behavior
is massively like subsidized and encouraged. And at some point,
I'm just like Were these Were these people right the whole time?
Were these people just always right the whole time that like
we need a match a massive like moral upheaval? But I I I don't
know. It's just like, dude, immoral behavior is just always massively
incentivized.
I don't know what to do about that. How do you do that?
How do you do that? How do you How do you get rid of it?
How do you fix it?
I don't know how to fix it. It's It drives me insane cuz I feel
like I don't want to do it still. I have the slave mindset, okay?
I have the slave
Where I'm like, even though even though I know it's like totally
would totally benefit me in being like a terrible not terrible
even in like acting in an immoral way, I don't want to do it.
I don't know what to do, man. Kick is quite literally spending
millions of dollars, like actually millions of dollars per month
to promote broadcasters, and then they're also paying them on
the back end through the partner program as well. And simultaneously,
they're doing this as a marketing strategy to bring people to
Kick. Stake had the playbook. You might have seen this even if
you're a pretty savvy social media person, you might remember
when you received Let's go!
We called this out. Think very much like across like all social
media. That's just this playbook, right? Like this is people
getting paid to post Stake logos everywhere. They took that playbook
and they and they optimized it and they put it out there for
Kick. And this has a dual um This has like a dual purpose of
like one, it it blows the streamers up, so it like it markets
them. And number two, it um uh it uh it it obviously brings people
to the website because 2.2 billion people are seeing the Kick
logo, and some of them like some very small percentage are going
to go to Kick and check it out. And uh this is going to boost
their live viewership as well. So, uh like on YouTube Shorts
and like TikToks and Reels and stuff, the conversions are bad
like percentage-wise. Like you you know, you might I really zero
zero. I don't really think about this how like
Clavicular blowing up even though he he's like not not entertaining.
And they've sort of figured out with social media how to advertise
his stuff in a way that is entertaining.
Like his actual streams where he's just talking, it's not very
it's like not amazing. It's not world-beating at all, right?
Like in terms of his desktop streams, DJ Akademiks is like 100
times more entertaining than Clavicular in terms of desktop streaming,
okay?
And I don't even think Clav's IRLs are very good, but But I didn't
even think about it, and it does make a lot of sense that
for Clavicular,
his rise can be like Kick's rise, too. Like it's actually benefiting
both
Like there's nobody who's losing in this. They're willing to
spend the money because he's everywhere, and having his name
attached to all of their like having their site attached to him
everywhere, the rise just helps both sides, right?
Like you can argue it hurts social media, it hurts advertising
companies, it hurts a lot of other people, but all of the benefits
are going to Eddie and Clavicular directly.
Um so, well done for Clav tying his like horse to this or yeah,
tying his wagon to this, very very very smart. I still don't
think he sees 24 at this rate. Although he did say I think he
said he's getting sober.
Maybe? Then he needs to figure out how to cuz I don't know, it
feels bad listening to him. This the one time I've ever felt
bad for this guy.
But like he basically says I can't I can't stream sober. I'm
like a loser. I like have social anxiety. I can't go out and
do IRLs sober. Right?
And it's like, oh, that feels rough, man. Like
Like I I kind of yeah, I feel bad for That like if he's cuz it
seems like he's genuinely having a real struggle with substances.
And it it does just it like it it sucks to see that he's basically
prioritizing all of the blow up on social media and stuff. And
it could be good, but it also could be disastrous. He seems like
he's actually
Yeah, he he he seems like he's actually going towards disaster
way more than it being good, to be honest. >> zero zero
zero zero 1%. Uh but it doesn't matter. If you have 2 billion
views and like the the aggregate of views of all these people
are are are way more, um you're going to have some people come
to your website. Now, look, crap I'm a marketer, okay? I'm a
branding agency owner. I like
This is smart marketing. Like like from their perspective, like
whatever you might think about the ethics of it, and you're well
within your rights to think about the ethics and the morals of
this. Um but but like that's like I I'm here to just present
the information.
I got to say though, like like from the perspective of like like
what Twitch did, which is like, okay, we've got to grow our website
somehow. Like we could pay streamers millions of dollars to stay
on the on the platform, and then we are mak- making those streamers
responsible for their own growth. So, all the old all the OGs
We'll see. that got the contracts and got paid on Twitch, they
all had to solve the growth problem themselves. Like bringing
viewers to the website was up to them. But Kick is saying, no,
we are actually going to do this for you, and we're going to
bring people to the website, and this is where our marketing
budget is going to go. So, they're spending tens of millions
of dollars because this is a like understanding that this is
a ecosystem that feeds them. That's why this exists, okay? Kick
would not be paying this kind of money if they didn't want to
actually build the platform. So, like from the perspective of
of a pure marketing perspective, this is a superior marketing
strategy than what Twitch did. It It just is. Like they're taking
the growth into their own hands. They're getting views on way
They're They're getting way more views. Like when Twitch paid
people to put money in to get get money to streamers, they were
still benefiting the content creator economy, and people made
a lot of money off there. There were people like Shroud and made
millions of dollars off that kind of stuff. Um a lot of people
that got paid contracts, all those top streamers, Pokimane, all
those It's funny because
Kick started by doing this, right?
And I I think I told Train at some point when I talked to him.
He's like, dude, don't do that. Don't do that cuz pretty soon
none of these platforms will be able to offer these kinds of
contracts cuz money's not going to be there. Don't offer these
people contracts. Like don't do that. They came up with a a great
strategy. Like all out of all the things I said, they made way
better decisions than even what I I thought was going to be good.
And they went and they started incentivizing people that actually
stream. Right? That's what KPP is.
You make people actually stream.
And then when they actually have to stream, it turns out they
don't just take your money and off like every streamer did with
Kick early. Right? X
X C C and Train obviously took the money, kind of off.
As much as I love Train, okay? Kind of took the money, off. 8
Ross took the money, off. All of Aiden's friends took the money,
off.
It's just wild when you do the like the the minimums, the contracts
with like, hey, you have to stream 40 hours a week or something,
and then we'll pay you X
You think like, oh, if you pay them hourly anyway,
they'll do more, but they don't. They just take like the crazy
amount of money, and they just do less every single time. people,
like they they did really well back when they were paying contracts,
but Twitch was basically paying them uh it's it's it's a and
then saying you're responsible for your own growth, and like
we hope that works out. Meanwhile, Kick says, no, we're going
to blast ourselves everywhere, and then we're also going to boost
these streamers as a as a side effect. So, like from a pure marketing
perspective, like dude, like you got to look at the hustle. Across
a billions and billions of views, it's actually a lot of impressions.
So, I think though that what we need to talk about next is kind
of the darker side of it. We We need We need to go over like
why exactly this works, and like what this is doing to the algorithm,
what this might mean for like the future of content, and I think
like how this is tricking algorithms, and like I think we need
to like go into like a little bit of the darker side. I'll be
honest, I could have just skipped right to this cuz this is like
the thing I actually want to talk about. Cuz from Devin's perspective,
this is all an existential risk to him. It's basically explaining
how none of these numbers are like super real, and they aren't
giving you a good indication of the genuine ability of these
people to convert somebody to a paying customer for any other
product.
And so, from the marketer's side, from Devin's side, where he
works with brands, and he says what to actually invest in, how
the does he see what's going on? How does he know?
Cuz now all of these people have like massively inflated view
numbers, massively inflated viewership numbers like live concurrent,
and it all seems to be provably fake, like provably propped up
massively. And so, how do you Cuz basically, if if all you have
is how well they actually convert once you're paying them or
once they're on some
then that's not any advantage at all. He His whole business is
going to be built on trying to take these numbers and make some
kind of sense of them. And I'm guessing that's why he's in all
of these Discords and [__] cuz he needs to actually
know what what people are doing, how much they're paying, who
the most astroturfed people are, and know to avoid them. Hey,
if if you're totally astroturfed, and I see you in every single
one of these Discords, and your clips are all over the place,
and your viewership numbers are here, you I'm going to go to
the person who's not in any of this [__] who's got
the same viewership numbers, and I'm going to give them way more
money than you cuz I'll get way more actual paying customers
out of that. that kind of stuff being said. So, before we do
that, that's right. We've got the secret call Zen Accali, this
is basically what Devin does. This is like sort of Devin's job.
It's to take either like he collects data from all the campaigns
he runs, and he tries to figure it out. And then he builds a
model that he could try to sell to advertisers saying, hey, I
know how to advertise in this space better than you. So, here's
what you should do. Let's kind of talk about the like first principles
logic of like how platforms think about things. How do I want
to I've explained this to you guys before, right? I'm going to
see how well my my knowledge maps up to matches on to Devin Nash's.
So, what I think it is is it's the snowball effect. The snowball
effect is what causes things to launch in the algorithm and Devin
Nash is going to explain why I talk about explicitly like the
blast off tweet and stuff like this. It is basically likes and
then it is conversion rate on
on like new views. So,
the way every algorithm works is basically it goes out to just
your followers first or even a small subset of your followers
and then for the percentage of those followers who engage or
like or view the video, let's say on
depending on how well it does, how well it retains people, how
well people like it, all of this stuff,
if it gets if it does well with that group, that first focus
group it does, it think of it as like focus grouping,
Focus grouping an initial barrage of people and then it's going
to build out from there. So, when when people view the tweet
early on and it gets likes early on, you never said that, I've
said that 100 times. I've said this exact rant 100 times. This
is why the blast off tweet's important. This is why when I talk
about juicing tweets, the whole juicer thing, I took that from
other people who do the same thing. It's just a very smart thing
to do. Talked about this many, many times. So, also relates to
your follower count and stuff. Yeah, so the percentage of
who like this stuff, that's it's doing like a focus group and
if it focus groups high, it builds out further. And likewise,
if it continues to focus group high with that further out range
of people and usually these will people who these will be people
who engage less with your stuff. If it focus groups high again,
it will keep going out. Think of them as like um like different
rings, okay?
Like uh Attack on Titan, the different walls, right? As you go
out.
And so, if you continue to get if it continues to do well with
more people it's fed to, it will continue to spread and propagate.
Okay? And that includes YouTube, that includes Twitter, that's
all of these things. So, it's it's always going to be seeing
how fast likes come in versus views, how high the engagement
rate is. If it's high engagement early on, it will be high engagement
later and it will continue to keep trying to blow it Basically
runs this experiment at different scales over and over and over
And that's why
with [clears throat] the clipping discords, people will like
retweet each other and stuff is because as you snowball that,
it snowballs and builds it out and it lets it propagate out
Very, very, very important.
This like this used to be different. Like it used to be the kind
of Instagram had their own way of doing this, Facebook had their
own way of doing this and then YouTube kind of just broke the
mold and YouTube was like oh, we just like straight up figured
it out and and and and then like pretty much everybody copied
them. Then TikTok came along and said, okay, we're going to use
that system but we're going to figure it out for short form.
So, we're going to we're going to take 7 to 60 second videos
instead of your 8 to 50 minute videos and we're going to make
these into we're going to make these popular and and the whole
idea of an of of an algorithm is it's it's simply to orient an
audience towards videos that they want to see. So, one of the
major signals for doing that is just deciding that content is
important in general is like the number of people they're talking
about. So, think about like
Okay. If if a news topic, like let's say something like a big
presidential thing happens or there's like big news in the world,
a big volcano erupts or
Um a wizard comes along and and and erupts a volcano through
sheer willpower and intent alone. How do we like hear about that
and like how does an algorithm know that that's important? Well,
a big part of it is just volume. Like a bunch of people saw the
volcano blow up and a bunch of people that didn't see the volcano
blow up want to talk about the volcano blowing up and a bunch
of analysts who are volcano specialists want to come in and talk
about the optics of the volcano blowing up. So, what happens?
Well, there's a lot of volume, right? There's a lot of like suddenly
there's just like a bunch of clips and there's a bunch of information,
there's a bunch of different people talking about that form of
content and now the algorithm goes oh, oh, that's important.
So, I I I we need to feature that. So, the algorithm says everybody
wants to talk about the volcano. I'm going to push the volcano.
So, imagine what kind of signal it sends when you have
clips in a month, in 30 days talking about this guy. The the
algorithm just
this is the most important person in the world. This guy is wants
everybody to talk about him. So, if you like had that experience
of like you you just like open anywhere and you're like it's
like clavicular, clavicular. You I what is looks max? I don't
even care about this guy. I never even googled anything like
this. What what is happening? It's because the algorithm is actually
getting tricked. Like like I like I promised you, this is not
a bait video. Like this is actually a game system.
They are uploading so many clips and the volume So, there's another
thing going on here that I hadn't considered, which does seem
interesting,
which is once Clavicular becomes a topic, you can actually astroturf
some collective platform wide piece of the algorithm that actually
continues the
That is something I'd never considered, but I also never had
the scale to consider it. So, it's uh that's pretty wild. volume
is so much that it's just telling the algorithm, hey, you should
talk about this person nonstop. He's blowing up. This is the
most important thing in the world. So, what is so crazy about
this and this is like the this is the nuttiest thing about this
video. Like it's just not an exaggeration that content creation
isn't about being interesting or engaging anymore. Like like
the previous type of content creation where you you had to like
have like a
and like I'm not saying that like some of the like some of these
creators don't have these It's hold on. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, there's like there's a bunch
of sales things here, right?
It's that
your churn rate doesn't matter because once you're like globally
scaled, once you're getting served to everybody across the planet,
churning people out doesn't even matter anymore, right? That
your churn rate is going to be like very high, literally doesn't
matter when you can market yourself top of funnel to every single
person in the world.
It's not that it it's not that you can't be you you don't have
to be interesting. It's that to to once you can show yourself
to everybody in the world, you can guarantee there is no person
boring enough that every single person in the world doesn't find
them interesting.
Except Stardust. But other than Stardust, every other person
that exists has somebody who will like their content, has like
thousands, tens of thousands, hundreds of thousands of people
who would like their content,
Outside of that one very special exception, there is nobody else.
All right?
And so, Clavicular doesn't have to be all that interesting. None
of these people have to be interesting at all, right? I will
say Neon is Neon actually is capable of being interesting and
yelling and like screaming and making content. Like none of these
people are totally worthless as content creators, okay? They're
all like narcissists, starve for attention. They all will do
the same thing. They're going to be relatively interesting,
Neon's a terrible person, but he's just capable of like screaming
and being funny in the moment. He just is. Anyway, um like almost
all of these people would
I think. So, it's not that it doesn't matter if you are intelligent,
it's that once you hit this level of scaling, once you have this
amount of capital to put in, to pay for the clippers, to astroturf
yourself this much, you there's literally you have to be so brutally
boring and terrible to watch
to not gain from it that like it's basically the bar is non-existent.
There is no bar.
personalities. It's subjective, right? Like what what is good
content and what isn't is like a very subjective thing, but I
will tell you like I guess subjectively in my opinion that a
lot of the people on this list are boring as hell and you might
agree with that or they're just outright just like not like like
kind of like skeezy type of people, right? Like like some of
them are great, but like like like some of them are legitimately
just boring as hell. How many viewers have you gained from the
clips? Um
I don't know. Hard to say. Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter. You
have 70,000 clips, you you go anywhere you want. It's it's just
not going to make a difference what your content is and that
kind of fundamentally under >> Wait. Do you guys know what
I mean by churn, right? Do you guys know the sales
like it's essentially the idea of retention. So, churning is
is like leaving some stream. So, it's like the idea of retention.
Basically, how many people you bring in versus how many people
churn out is your retention rate. And you can have like a a really
bad retention rate. You could have like a 1% retention rate or
a 0.5% retention rate that people find your stream and they don't
they they like literally don't like you so they leave. They never
watch again. But once you have like a billion or billions of
impressions in a month, it doesn't matter what your content is
or what you have to say. Like when I talked about Clavicular
saying how I can't stream sober, that was like somewhat compelling
to me. That could be enough for a lot of people to just go and
watch his stream from then on,
And even though most people will find him boring or most people
might find him off-putting, it doesn't matter. You've got so
many impressions. The top of funnel is so wide that even though
the funnel like really narrows quickly and like barely drips
out at the end, the problem is like you can pour the whole ocean
into the top. So, the drip at the end is like massive amounts.
Whereas somebody could be very entertaining, very compelling,
but if they've got, you know, a a faucet essentially for the
top of funnel, it doesn't matter they could be 100% retention
right? They it doesn't matter even if they retain everybody,
they're not going to retain more clips than Clav whose top of
funnel instead of a faucet is the
You have 70,000 clips, you you go anywhere you want. It's it's
just not going to make a difference what your content is and
that kind of fundamentally undermines like the whole purpose
of like what
content creation was kind of is. Like content creation was kind
of a voting system. It was kind of like oh, like we think this
guy like Mark Rober is interesting. So, we're going to like watch
his video and then that video and then The real solution here
is to
map these networks on the on the platform side. Unfortunately,
there's another it's all advertising getting So, again, it's
going to be funny or interesting to see how Devin talks about
this cuz the platforms themselves actually could map these networks.
They could track these networks. They could easily like start
essentially like blacklisting or shadow banning a lot of the
people in these networks who are operating in this at this level,
right? To astroturf things. They could do that. But they're incentivized
not to cuz it's massive it's massive viewership on their platform,
right? It's all the cultural stuff happening on their platform.
So, they're massively incentivized not to do
Everybody, the platforms, Kick, Twitter,
the people paying, Eddie,
Clavicular, and the influencers, Clavicular and and Asmongold
and anybody else who's in that list, Nina Drama or whatever,
right? All of these people massively benefiting. People getting
[__] in the ass, advertisers.
And it's funny cuz it is it's the problem Trainwreckz described
where the advertisers aren't getting their value. It's It's the
problem that Mizkif and a bunch of other people described about
Mizkif where like, "Hey, if you're botting a whole bunch, advertisers
offer you a lot of money, but they don't get anything out of
that, right?"
It's It's that problem
across all of social media
amplified massively.
And I don't know like is that just going to make it so that people
find advertising on social media is
Won't they just stop advertising? Well, they'll stop advertising
as much or they'll rely on people like Devin. It's probably It's
probably a gold rush for people like Devin. If you If you know
the advertising landscape online and you can convince people
of that and sign big brands, I'm guessing if Devin can show like
a meaningful return in terms of like uh of conversion rate, if
he can show a meaningful like a meaningful step up from the rest
of the pack, he's going to make insane amounts of money. That
would be massive.
They won't stop advertising, they'll start spanning spanning
more. Um
maybe. Some people will stop
It'll just depend. It'll go down to like there will be another
thing where there's authority reestablished, right? So, you watched
originally when social media first broke down and and people
didn't have trust in news, there was tons of people doing stuff
all the time. And then it sort of built up into these figures,
right? And it's happening very fast. So, over decades it took
to build up CNN and Fox News and all of these major news companies,
right? And then over just years you looked up like Tucker Carlson
on X and Tim Pool and Candace Owens and all these people, right?
And you're going to watch that as people see those those creators
not follow their their principles, that will like disintegrate
as well and you'll see it like raise back up. So, there will
be I think probably like influencers people see as I can advertise
my product with them reliably. And I think there'll be like trusted
people you advertise with and it won't be just, you know, advertising
It might end up end up advertising on the platform and lead to
a lot of these platforms specifically working with like individuals
more.
And again, that'll all be that'll all be facilitated through
middlemen like Devin. Like people who have the expertise and
can get like meaningful signal through the noise. Cuz that'll
be a That'll be the biggest thing is how do you cut down on all
of this noise? And everyone's like, "Yay, that video's going
to do well." And then Mark Rober was like, "Wow, I got rewarded
for that. I'll make more videos." And like so the cycle goes.
But now the algorithm will just pick up anybody, no matter how
uninteresting or how boring at this volume. And it's just going
to push it no matter what because it's taught that the sheer
volume of posts about the same thing equals that it's important.
So, this is what like like this is where we get into kind of
the the the dark side of the issue. Wait, you are not even choosing
the content that you you watch anymore. The algorithm by volume
it and
It's only if you don't curate your algorithm. Like I get very
few Clavicular clips on my actual Twitter
Like the algorithm does listen to you. It's just most people
have no interest in curating their algorithm at all. Who's a
Clavicular? He's coming. He He's He's coming. And it was some
Kick executive that decided that for you, right? Like like like
it's it's not the fact that he organically blew up by the vote
of the crowd by by engagement by likes by um and and that's that's
that sort of thing. There's an aspect of that, right? Like like
there's there's there's a part of that that's true. I mean it's
not a big part given that number two on Devin Nash's little chart
there is Nina Drama, right? That Asian girl salted the dude who
like literally has never had an intelligent thought in her entire
life. Oh, wait, is that Hold on. I'm thinking of some different
Nina or something, some other Asian person. It's a different
person.
never never seen a clip of this person. I Oh, sorry, I've not
seen a clip
that I recognize her from. I don't even know who this is. Nina
Lynn, that's who. Anyway, this guy don't know him. I've seen
this name before, don't know who this is. I think this is a different
language though. Uh let's see. Ram Dude, Rampage, I'm
And no shade to Rampage who's been funny. You know what? All
the clips I've seen of Rampage, he seems like somewhat funny
at least. I was going to say I don't know anybody who would actually
watch Rampage, but Rampage has kind of been funny sometimes when
I've seen him in clips. But that's just the clips. I got to imagine
that stream is boring as I'll be real. But he kind of blew up
because somebody decided or or or somebody gave a lot of money
to somebody and said, "Hey, um we're going to pay 60
We're going to pay for 69,000
views and 2,000 people full-time to just literally spam social
media with all of this stuff." And that's also why like that
that like that what I what I also does is that drives down the
um the the quality of the clips as well because if there have
already been
clips submitted and then you watch the
one, it doesn't have to be interesting content. Like it's your
lived experience is you just watch a bad clip, but because the
algorithm had 50,000
videos before it, it was just like, "No, this is He's going to
like this." And you're like, "I don't really like this." And
it's like, "You You do like it. You have to like it. 50,000 people
other videos said that that that it's there. You You better like
it right now." Dude, um
watch the second that
the second that they take the global pay scale that applied to
like tech and a bunch of other like asynchronous jobs and they
start applying it to like third world
there's going to be like a like a actual holocaust of content
online.
It's going to be [__] crazy. You guys have no idea.
Like like it's going to be it's going to be insane. You saw Drew
Pavlou freak out, right? When when Elon suggested that that actually
we're going to make this based on like region. And Drew Pavlou
lost his
Uh so so many people lost their It is going to like upend everything
when that happens. And it will happen. Cuz at very at the very
minimum the the advertisers are not going to be willing
like pay out for this, right? This like totally astroturfed like
third world content.
It's just It's not going to work anymore. Now, here's another
one. You don't like that one, take this one. Again, like Twitter
Twitter must understand that they're cutting massively into their
own bottom line. Like long-term
they're actually they are actually [__] themselves.
That advertisers will eventually just stop spending on Twitter
cuz the spend won't won't be worth the anything. Everybody everything
I ever hear about advertising on the internet by the way just
further incentivizes or further pushes me towards like Google
are the only people who have anything figured out. That's why
they'll always have a place in the world cuz they're the only
people who figured out advertising at all. And your dollars will
always go further with Google. It won't be fake numbers. They'll
figure out ways to actually cuz they heavily heavily
heavily focus on any sort of like astroturfed engagement and
killing it. That's probably why I don't get Cloud videos on YouTube.
Like it's probably actually very very very difficult to astroturf
Clavicular into YouTube.
I'm not even joking. Was that even a question with Google? No,
but they're the only people who have figured it out to any real
extent.
And and and now you're just like, "Ah, like like like leave me
alone." Like right like so we are no longer in social media.
Nothing you do is social media. Social media is like you know
on Discord and say hello to your friend. Discord is the most
social media we have now. Like there's like How When's the last
time you went on Twitter and you talked to your friend? It never
happens, right? Like you're talking to the people that and and
and you're consuming the topics that the algorithm says that
you should consume. And the the the the the the the the the the
the content that you watch isn't even stuff that you choose anymore.
The the the interest that you have are no longer social. It's
it's not like keeping up with your college buddies. It's it's
it's it's it's it's algorithm media. It's it's interest media.
I would say is a better word for social media now. Like um I
I I don't think uh like social media is even the proper word
for it anymore. It's kind of a different thing. So, like you're
not even choosing the content you watch anymore, man. It's crazy.
So, what do we do about it? >> word you would use for that?
Right? Like last section. I mean like what to do if there is
anything to be done. But just a couple of like observations and
commentary from, you know, your your your your friend the Super
quick. We're finally on to the actual solutions, which is going
to be my favorite section. It just so happened I I made this
post on X.
It was about this. Before I made this video and and and and like
the the post on X twitter.com/devinnash
I post like really long-form analysis on stuff there. And like
literally the same day this guy came out with like I'm not saying
he like he just like wrote this himself. I think it was just
a total coincidence that he came out came out at the same time.
Yeah, I've got this tweet and this generated like a Twitter thread
as well on the same topic. But yeah, this Ed Elson guy also released
some stuff. He was the one who I saw Hasan fans getting like
mad at this guy. It was very funny. Hold on, let me pull this
guy's thread up real This guy made a
like his own little thread about the clipping economy. And if
you saw this graphic, this is from this guy, okay? Showing that
like Hasan gets live viewership here at this rate, Nick Fuentes
19,000, Clavicular 16,000.
And the funny thing is is What does it say? "Clips are no longer
the byproduct of the main product, they're the main product.
No matter the size of the show, they they the ultimate reach."
But that was always the case.
That was the whole point of clips even from the time of live
stream fail. Nobody's ever even denied this or thought differently.
This how many people you can maintain concurrently is massive.
That is a very good indicator of how popular a stream is if you
could get rid of the bot
Is the number of people you can actually maintain concurrently.
This 706,000, this is not even guaranteed to be something.
There's a lot of stuff getting served that people will skip past
that you have no idea what the retention rate is on this stuff.
Right? You never know.
yeah, it's just I I think this this graphic was kind of goofy
in the first place. Also, it doesn't take long form content views
into consideration like anything on YouTube anywhere else. So,
it is kind of a silly thing to suggest that like clips are the
big product. They're really not. And they're not where the streamer
makes any of their money, either. Right? The whole point like
you could say clips are no longer the the main product. Or sorry,
the streamers are no longer the main product. But, all these
streamers are paying for the clips so that they get people watching
the live stream and donating to the live stream.
That's the whole point. And they can pay unique viewer There's
no way to do this. You can't do this. There's no way to find
this number.
Anyway, so this this is the Ed Elson guy, right? Ed Elson? I
think it's Ed Ed Elson. Yeah, Ed Elson. Elson. Okay, well. I've
never heard of this dude. Um doesn't even follow me, I guess.
But, um he put this thing out there called the clipping economy
and it basically concludes the same thing that I'm telling you
right now, which is like, "Man, clips are taking over like a
lot of the attention economy." There's some
very weird stuff in this article. Um I mean like basically what
he's saying is we are we have now moved from like a content economy
to like the way that it was before to like now everything's just
clips. And there's some stuff in here that's like a little bit
questionable like this graph for example where you see here it
says average live viewership versus clip viewership. So, you
can take a person like Hasan [__] who averages about
33,000 uh viewers live and then it says like like in the same
amount of time for April he's already gotten 700,000 views on
his um
on his his content is long like long and short form content.
This is disingenuous that the the like the person that that wrote
this article well, I think they should keep doing work um because
they they write interesting things. I just encourage everybody
to write interesting things. Um they're they're probably not
in this field in the same way. Like so this for example is not
correct. Right? This is a false equivalence because Hasan might
have
at at one given time. So, when you go on his stream, you see,
"Oh, he has 33,000 viewers." But, that No, this There's just
no point in comparing these numbers. These numbers are incomparable.
That was about to say represents a snapshot in time. There is
in fact like a churn and the churn is going quite quickly so
that the end of his stream will actually represent a unique viewership
of much much higher. The number will be way closer to this number.
Also, that 33,000 viewers is just counting like one stream. He
streams every single day for for for for tons of people. So,
in reality, his like total live streaming exposure and that's
most likely true for click clavicular as well. The viewership
is actually equal. So, this is like not a very good representation
of this this concept.
You can't like really pay attention to this. This is kind of
like a critical mistake with this article. But, the the fund
the foundation of it, which is like the clip economy is big and
it's being gamed, that's good.
And I and I think that's true. Um and I I think like a much better
way to sort of interpret this is just to see this here just to
get an idea of like, "Okay, well, these are like all the views
that just Kick is doing." That that that that show how much of
like your social media experience, your interest media experience
is being dictated by this. So, I do agree that we're in a clipping
economy. And in my post on X, I
I ended up saying at the end like my conclusion here was straight
up like
wherever you stand on it, streaming, live streaming, and and
kind of content creation in general is just a much more gamed
ecosystem now and it will remain so. There is no way to really
police this behavior cuz it hijacks the algorithm. Like we talked
about how the algorithm kind of perceives um like [clears throat]
importance.
I guess you could have like individual employees at these companies
like ban the individual people, but it would be like very weird
and like very hard to do. So, there's no So, like live streaming
like streaming as relates to Kick and it's just kind of a gamed
ecosystem. Like there will be very few broadcasters that come
up in the next few years that aren't utilizing this strategy.
Now, notably, there are broadcasters that are coming up not utilizing
it. I I think the biggest example of the one is the the video
that I did before this, which was an analysis on the Burnt Peanut.
And the Burnt Peanut is a person who is to my knowledge not using
that clipping service yet. The Burnt Peanut is just straight
up botting. And I'll be honest with you. I said this in a at
least one or two Discords I'm in, okay? I actually judge Trump
voters, triple Trump voters who voted all three times for Donald
Trump, I judge them less harshly than the Burnt Peanut viewers.
If there are actual genuine Burnt Peanut viewers, they are the
worst humans in America. Doesn't matter if they vote Democrat,
it literally doesn't They are the worst humans in America.
By far. Okay? If you're above 18 and you watch the Burnt Peanut,
you are a terrible person. You are a terrible person, you are
a terrible person, you are a terrible person. Very cute, what
are you doing? Very cute, don't do this to me. Very cute, don't
do this Don't do this to me, okay? Do not do this to me. Not
right now. I can't take I don't do it. Don't do it, man. it.
Um he's either way he's doing a couple other tricks. Not like
for example, he has a 24/7 stream online. So, he hosts the 24/7
stream when he goes offline. The the 24/7 stream then hosts him
when he goes online. So, that is kind of a that's set up by his
agency. They're real smart guys. And a lot of top streamers do
that now to not churn viewers so that the AFK viewers like sit
like sit at the bottom of that stream and then they they kind
of continuously rehost themselves. So, you might have an AFK
viewer for like 4 days that still counts as a viewer, right?
Cuz he just left his computer on or something or left his TV
on. So, there's a little bit of that, but like Burnt not gaming
that system and he's like the biggest streamer on Twitch right
now. So, it's like there are people that can still come up by
not utilizing this, but it's like you like it's like climbing
up a mountain of ice without the little ice picks. Like sure
there's like some guy that might be able to like dig his hands
in and just like right right, but like overall like you're going
to have to utilize this system to to be competitive, which kind
of sucks, I think. I mean Um I don't think this is entirely true.
I do think you can climb through genuinely like making connections,
making yourself a better the about the like a part of the conversation.
I think it's not just this. I think this is the best way to grow
if you just want numbers and all of that. Like realistically,
I should probably be spending money doing stuff like this. Probably.
Okay?
But, I wasn't totally sure where I wanted to go with the stream
for a while. So, I I was not I I was like aware in the background
that maybe I should be spending money on like paying clippers
directly and and getting that running. But, I really wasn't sure
where I wanted to go. I've got more of a concrete vision now,
which is actually not that far off from what we were doing in
the first place. So, it's it's kind of funny. It's like politics
and drama the mix. Maybe bleeding more towards politics over
time. Okay? It's it's it's that. But, um
I think if you just are genuinely a part of the conversation
in a way where you're getting talked about, you people will find
you. I do think so. I think there's a way to participate and
grow organically. It's just that you lose your chance at like
the the insane parabolic growth.
Like the totally ludicrous parabolic
And maybe that's just not worth trying to get worth giving up
on. Maybe that's something you should be doing. That that's um
that's a that's kind of iffy. Um I I I also think so we're talking
With this like Devin Nash is talking about it. Like the adoption
curve on this, it's almost like maybe it's worth doing this.
But, the meta is like the meta is going to be moving now. I think
I think the big focus going to be on platforms fixing this problem.
And then there's going to be like a slight meta shift to something
else. And we'll see what that is. about like overall concepts.
So, we're now in the clipping economy. That was like number one.
We are now in the clipping economy. And like for that, I agree.
And I think it's going to stay that way for the foreseeable future.
Now, somebody
in my comments,
you smart guy you, mentioned that it is possible that LLMs get
advanced enough that they can kind of detect this behavior. And
then as a result, they're kind of added into algorithms and they
suppress it down. I I don't know. It would be hard to differentiate
between like an actual viral It's not LLMs.
It wouldn't be LLMs. It would be identifying like the networks,
the non-organic traffic.
And deadening it. YouTube already does this significantly.
Um YouTube used to hit if DGG embedded YouTube videos, you YouTube
would like hit those videos.
Like there were times where on when I had a YouTube channel where
my YouTube videos would get embedded in like DGG chat and YouTube
would hit those for like
Sorry, what was it? Like view viewership
So, it's it's about detecting like the networks that actually
propagate this stuff. viral topic and one that's being farmed
just by the way this works. But, that's a cool concept. That
that that's kind of a cool idea. Um Next thing I think in terms
of this like what to do about it like section is um you know,
live viewership in general when it comes to streaming like just
doesn't really matter.
It's like the long form stuff is just more of a way to to to
get content to do clips these days. Most people will follow everything
through short form. So, if you have heard of a of a broadcaster
like Asmongold, like you've probably seen like some kind of clip
of him rather than like watch his live stream. I don't think
this will change. I I don't think that real brand power comes
from like live viewership. And for that matter, I also think
that
brand power doesn't really come from short form, either. Like
whatever you think about Asmongold, um and I'm not here to pass
a value on anyone. I just gotten out of that style of my life.
I just want to I want to like champion everybody. I want to like
like be the the like at at the highest levels for anybody that's
actually doing anything, okay? For the most part. Um, so from
a pure marketing perspective,
you look at a creator like Asmongold, and this dude is like consistently
hitting seven to eight long-form
20-minute videos
every single day.
Plus, he's part of the clipping system. Okay, so like in terms
of brand authenticity,
like we're going to be hearing from Asmongold. He's right here,
by the way. He's got the 66 clippers, 2,000 videos, and 70 million
views, which I think a lot of those views are just his own views
on his long-form content, but yeah. Like um, I think we're going
to be hearing from people like this who have set up like a long-form
strategy on their own media for a long period of time. And I
think Asmongold, like I mean, from a marketing standpoint, I
think he's one of the most impressive people out there. Like
like I've always Yeah, I've thought this. The way Asmongold's
got it like systematized at this point, and it all works. It's
all like incredibly effective.
And it's it's very impressive how he has it going.
Um, I To be honest, sometimes I do get the feeling that there
is like a force behind Asmongold that is not just Asmongold.
Like there I feel like he's either got a group chat or he's got
like something going on where Yeah, there's something going on
behind Asmongold that like gets him to this scale. No, I don't
think it's Night Media, cuz it's it's probably led by Asmongold.
But I'm saying that somehow Asmongold
always knows perfectly how to Like
He phrases things in this way that he doesn't get banned, and
he also says the most offensive thing he can. And he does it
so often that I feel like it's very intentional.
And it's on a cadence that is impressive. Like he will react
to stuff the second it pops, and he will have it. So that that
leads me to believe in the other direction where he like maybe
it is organic, and it is just mostly him. Cuz he can he can get
the exact right tone sometimes
within like hours of something drop like an hour or two of something
dropping, he can get the exact right tone to generate like maximum
outrage for some new breaking news story. I mean, I bet you could
do it. Yeah, but I'm evil, so when other people could do it,
I think it's >> Like he he's he's really understands the
system or his team does. I think he's a smart guy, though. Um,
and he knows like not only how to address different topics and
and and and communicate them, but he also knows how to create
long-form content. Like you literally almost can't get through
a single day of his content. Like like here's a 2-hour one, 2
hours and 30 minute like you'd have to be watching this guy all
day every day to consume everything he posts out in a week. So
this in a day, excuse me. So this kind of thing is going to last.
I think a lot of these sort of like short-form videos like are
just like going to sort of fizzle out. People be like, "Okay,
like I get it. Like this guy is like like kind of the talk of
the town." And then you can you kind of get your 15 minutes,
and um, you you you peace out. It's kind of over. Okay. Like
like um, it it it it for most of these people, I I don't think
they're going to stick around. Um, for the people that are doing
authentic long-form strategy, and like they they are really thinking
through their marketing plan and their brand power, and they
have like a unique more so I think they'll be around.
in terms of the ethics and morality of
I think you've got two perspectives.
Uh, the the the first one's going to be the one that I think
most people have, which is um, this is astroturfing content creators,
and it's creating false ecosystems.
Um, I I think that's a perfectly fine way of looking at it. >> Like
like like um, it it because it is very true that like a content
creator that is interesting,
um, but but by like the It's like the Stratton Oakmontification
of content.
Like like everything you saw in Wolf of Wall Street, it's like
all of the same
Give it to her comp. Yeah, it's If you go to my my Twitter, JSTLK
with an underscore, not krillin, it's pinned. The Twitter comp
is. So it's like it's exactly from like the Wolf of Wall Street
playbook, where it's like, "Hey, the downsides to this doesn't
even matter. Like if you get caught and banned, you'll have made
so much money. You'll have made you've gotten so many views,
made so much money that it won't matter. And also, by then, you'll
be like institutional, and they won't even ban you. They'll just
give you like a fine or a slap on the wrist."
Like that's that's it's the exact same mindset and process.
And at that point, again, I go back to maybe just maybe these
guys had some kind of these guys these guys these guys had some
kind of point about like the decay of the West or something.
Cuz it's like, "Okay, well, that's just true. Yeah." They become
institutional, they don't get penalized, and we just have to
go on with our days.
I I guess. I guess so. >> objective definition that most
people would look at them and think about it. Like like oh, that
person is interesting, right? Will will just get blown out by
the massive trumpet that is 60,000 clips from a totally uninteresting
person. Or it's 10,000 or whatever the number is, whoever the
influence I think the funny thing about this is that like Fuentes
did this to some extent.
But I think Fuentes is the example of what happens when you are
capable of being interesting or funny. Right? Where you actually
generate like word of mouth through those same things. I think
Klav is going to fall off. I think a lot of people who do this
fall off, or they just they they they get come and they go, like
Devin says. But if you are a person who has some genuine message,
is like genuinely interesting in some way, or funny, holy you're
going it's going to be like nuclear. That's why Fuentes had that
generational run, the huge blow-up,
Klav is going to die before he falls
Yeah, I mean, I think so. That's right. Um, and that influencer,
by virtue of the fact that they have a paid system behind them,
uh, that is that is generating all this media, will just get
propelled to the top of the algorithm in all the ways that we
explained in the video. And it's Astroturfing is a term that
means like you're just kind of creating like a false campaign
that's like not really real. And I think a lot of people will
um, look at the ecosystem and say we are we are worse for this
being the case. And they're I think they're perfectly within
their rights to think that. Um, and I I and like I try to stay
out of the like the personal opinions, but I would lean more
towards that direction than I would the next opinion, which is
like, "Well, it's it's a it's a new age marketing campaign to
drive viewers, especially like for Kick to drive viewers to itself."
Um, and
Okay, like like like I I I can see that from the perspective
of a marketer. That that like again, like this is a superior
campaign to run. And like were I at the top of a platform like
Kick and making decisions like this, I would probably make the
same decisions to market my platform out, um,
at the expense of I guess the entire content creator ecosystem,
who knows, you know? So so so or maybe I wouldn't. But the point
is like they're making them, and um, and I I understand it from
that marketing perspective. Okay. But then I like here's a really
interesting
And uh, this is from from from Nick Polom. Props. One of the
only other influencers that uses his full name. Um, NMP, he's
a live streamer on Twitch, and he he posted something that I
I just like I I I wanted to include in this video, cuz I I just
didn't think about it. I was like, "Oh, this is actually huge."
So he he posted this. "I'm curious with all of these clippers
and them getting paid to do so, aren't these mini hashtag ads?"
So he's referring to the FTC guideline that says that if you
have paid for somebody to do content, that needs to be an ad.
Like you need to disclose that's an ad. So did
I do Oh, [__]
Oh, this is so perfect. I didn't think about this.
This is the same thing that happened. We'll see how fast it goes.
But this is the same thing that happened
with every other like major app that did land and expand. Is
is you basically find something that's regulated, and you use
technology to get around that regulation. So if you basically
just totally decentralize something, like taxi drivers, just
make it so it's a bunch people who are just driving their own
cars, and they're just going to pick people up, and there's no
nothing wrong with that. Why would they need to be
Right? And here it is. Dude, these guys are like clippers just
doing stuff with their own accounts, and why would it have to
be regulated? What what What's going on, man? Whole bunch of
different Discords, and it all moves too fast. It can be spun
up and down so quickly that there's just no way to effectively
regulate it.
Yeah. Dude, this This is my This is like how you make a billion
dollars is you find an industry that's regulated, that has like
legal red tape, and you just find a way to use technology to
make it too hard to punish you for violating the
And
that's what this is. It's just obviously that, and I didn't even
see the pattern until Devin just pointed it out, or until Nick
Polom pointed it out. I didn't see the overlap, and it's so obvious
now. That just hit me like a ton of bricks, how obvious that
is. Do they not need to disclose they're being paid? And that's
a federal requirement in the United States of America, but you've
got to do it. You might see like those hashtag ads for any kind
of like sponsorship stuff. I do So so my job outside of making
these videos, and this this is just fun, right? Um, my job is
to I support brands. I work for brands, and I build them big
influencer campaigns, and I pay influencers to to to to talk
about products or talk about services that these brands have,
and we get we make the brands a lot of money. But we have to
put hashtag ad on every single one of those videos that we do,
because they're sponsored videos, and the FTC guidelines require
us to
Yeah. So here's the thing. Now Now, you say it's all the smart
decision over here, Devin. Are you going to go outside of those
guidelines? What are you going to do? Cuz now the smart decision
is to break the law. Just like crypto rug pulls early on, just
like all The smart decision, the self-serving decision is to
break the law. And how long can any society that operates this
way last when every single person is incentivized Every intelligent
person is incentivized to act in the most immoral way. And the
only answer The answer is, unfortunately, okay, the answer is
extreme punishment for the individuals who did it while they
thought they wouldn't get punished. Bro, I'm seeing this like
self-similar stuff all over the place. This like the idea of
the Trump administration. The Trump administration are doing
this with government right now. That system is not called capitalism.
That is not what capitalism is. It's not inherent in capitalism
in any way. It is how capitalism is functioning currently. It's
not inherent to the system.
What a brain-dead engagement.
China China gets China kind of gets around this. Except for China,
they just control all of the the actual regulations.
And so if you're like and it's all run through the state.
So like you just don't have the opportunity to make a company
that could violate the law that way. Or you would just get like
Dover for it. It's rough. Every intelligent person is incentivized
to act immorally. I mean outside of what the current rules are.
There's like a There's a set of rules which are the law or which
is the law that everybody's supposed to operate within. And we're
obviously operating outside of the spirit of the law. Yeah, it's
um it's rough. I don't know. Hate that. Uh so Nick kind of brought
up like something I didn't even think about, which is like why
aren't all of these paid clippers required to do that? And the
answer is because like we're operating like a gray hat area of
marketing right now where it's this is just not being considered.
So this is kind of a big deal, right? Like like if the eye of
Sauron were to turn on this and like like you know what's interesting
is like I mean like Trump just did an ad with the UFC and the
UFC sponsored by stakes. So like
How does the eye of Sauron not turn on Is the question. How does
it not? I I I actually don't even know how the eye of Sauron
doesn't turn onto this. What point does the government like kind
of be like is this What are we doing here, right? And you know
at the point where somebody might like like report this or something.
Like it could get interesting. So curious how it's different
than let's say McDonald's paid me to tweet about their burgers.
And I thought about this for a while. Like like when I I told
them thanks like I'm going to put this in the video because honestly
like like to me I mean like you would need somebody to legally
sort this out. But to me that's exactly the same thing. Like
you're paying for an ad for your stream because you're you're
you're quite literally paying a paid clipper. The clipper is
getting paid to promote your services and they're getting paid
to do that. I mean that's like kind of textbook definition of
that to me. I think that's the same thing as a hashtag ad. That
would need to be sorted out in court. Like to be very clear that
is not well that that's not the way it's going to end up yet.
Like we don't know. But what we do know is that like for influencer
based content
content that is sponsored or content that's sponsored by brands
directly or things like that. Um you got to you got to you got
to disclose it. I I do that for thousands of influencers every
month. So um it's interesting. It's just just a very interesting
thought here that I wanted to include. Um I think it's a real
important point. Couple of Actually an incredibly important point
and like it's it's crazy that he didn't think of that. It's crazy
also
that NMP thought of it. I cuz I should have thought of it. I
feel stupid for not thinking of it. Cuz it's an argument I go
back to again and again and again about how like the gig economy
is really things up for a lot of people. But I'm I'm shocked
NMP found that. It's very >> points Oh, but he's I guess
he's technically like the creative director for OTK. So he probably
has a lot of experience here. And he's probably literally thinking
like how the do I advertise for my company without breaking the
law? How do I do these clipping things without breaking the law?
>> we've got here that that I that I I I I think are interesting.
Wherever you stand on it
streaming isn't like what it used to be. And and content creation
is not what it used to be. The ecosystem is different and it
will remain that way I think. Because again as we were talking
about earlier. And livestreaming especially is now like a totally
rigged game because there is no way you're like you are 10 viewer
15 viewer person and you're not utilizing these strategies. And
like look like I just want to talk to like there are a lot of
small content creators that watch this channel I know. You're
not hopeless, okay? Like you could go get a couple of your friends
together. You could go get two or three people and you could
go make some clips. Um post them on different platforms on different
accounts and see how they do. You Will you get two million views
and will you become a big killer? No. But will you meaningfully
increase the amount of viewership and exposure you have relative
to your own work that you put in? Yes, you will do that, right?
So I don't want anybody to lose hope because you you could you
could definitely um boost yourself by doing like some minute
miniaturized version of this. But but certainly like in terms
of like if you want to go up there and be like the top percentage
of people, it is a rigged game now. And content creation in general
like across like a lot of social media platforms is going this
way because of services like we talked about these Discord servers
and things like that. Um and however that makes you feel, I mean
like you are within your right to feel it. For me personally,
like you know, I don't like to get involved these days in this
stuff as far as like my personal opinion. Two reasons for that.
One, I'm out of the game. Like I I like like I work for brands.
So my interest is in like interesting marketing stuff, interesting
advertising stuff. My job is to educate. Um two, I just want
people to make their own decisions. I don't like the idea of
Isn't this like critically the number one problem you have? You
work for brands? Like you do work You don't work for ad like
advertising at all? You work on any of that [__]
like me influencing your opinion or anything like that. But if
you must know like where I kind of stand on it.
Obviously I'm like the old man like shaking his fist at the clouds
like do you remember when people were actually interested? And
like I feel a little bit of that. Um but I also acknowledge like
this is the ecosystem that we're in. Um I'm just glad that I
could be here and post videos like this because this took a lot
of research to do. >> This this is This This took me several
weeks to figure out exactly how this functions and get all these
individual data points I don't think I don't think any of this
was shocking to us. There are like a couple little points in
here that are like maybe updating my knowledge. I think we had
a good idea of how all of this stuff worked and we talked about
it on stream like several times now.
it's funny. I The things that are interesting are the data points
and the scale. I I don't think I knew the scale. The scale is
pretty insane for clippers specifically.
And watching how that out that that chart that he posted essentially
to me sort of explains the weird disparate gap between how entertaining
somebody is and how big their viewership is or how many how many
their clips get pushed, right? That chart like explains all of
it to me.
So it's like oh I knew this I knew something weird was happening.
Well, here's the thing that explains all of it. So good video
overall. I'm a fan.
Isn't this like critically the number one problem you have? You
work for brands? Like you do work You don't work for ad like
advertising at all? You work on any of that [__]
like me influencing your opinion or anything like that. But if
you must know like where I kind of stand on it.
Obviously I'm like the old man like shaking his fist at the clouds
like do you remember when people were actually interested? And
like I feel a little bit of that. Um but I also acknowledge like
this is the ecosystem that we're in. Um I'm just glad that I
could be here and post videos like this because this took a lot
of research to do. This this is This This took me several weeks
to figure out exactly how this functions and get all these individual
data points I don't think I don't think any of this was shocking
to us. There are like a couple little points in here that are
like maybe updating my knowledge. I think we had a good idea
of how all of this stuff worked and we talked about it on stream
like several times now.
it's funny. I The things that are interesting are the data points
and the scale. I I don't think I knew the scale. The scale is
pretty insane for clippers specifically.
And watching how that out that that chart that he posted essentially
to me sort of explains the weird disparate gap between how entertaining
somebody is and how big their viewership is or how many how many
their clips get pushed, right? That chart like explains all of
it to me.
So it's like oh I knew this I knew something weird was happening.
Well, here's the thing that explains all of it. So good video
overall. I'm a fan.